Hey Guys Welcome back to the Workshop in This Video Today, we're doing Some a little bit Different
We're Making the suckers that's right
We're gonna Show you how to take a mold of your thumb and then cast it in Hard Candy so you Can Literally have A
Sucker of your Thumb now nate has Worked Hard Prototype of This Project for us today so Once You go ahead Mate and Show Us
How to get Started There's A lot of good Candy Recipes out There
We're Gonna Show you one of the easiest ones and also how to build it up to turn it Into something spectacular and
Personal Not only, do You get to Make some Delicious Candy for this Project but it's
Also a great way to practice the basics of Molding and Casting Since
We are Going to be Molding and Casting one of the Main supplies you're Going to need Is a Two-Part mold Putty I have A
Couple Different Brands of Mold Putty that I was able to Buy at
A local Craft Store Both are Easy To use Relatively Inexpensive and are Food safe some of the other Materials
We're Going to need are Corn syrup White sugar A
Flavoring of your Choice and Food dye some other Supplies Are Going to need our disposable Plastic cups Clothes Pins, Lollipop Sticks
Measuring Cups High Heat Spatula and A Candy Thermometer and of Course A pot to cook
Him You want to Make sure that it's large enough that you Can hold all of your ingredients Easily
But Small Enough that your Candy Thermometer will Still reach what's Cooking near the Bottom
Now since I'm gonna be Molding my Thumb for this one I'm Gonna have to lose the Glove
Most disposable Cups Are large Enough that if You, were to fill them with silicone you Would waste some valuable Putty
We're Going to cut this cut Down to size to Make it fit our Thumb
Perfectly measure where you should cut the cup. Line your Thumb up with it leaving About half an inch from the Bottom. For my
Thumb This Line Perfectly Matches Where, We want to trim the Cup.
The next Important Step is to Make Sure you've Trimmed the nail and wash your thumb Thoroughly. The silicone Putty will pick up every Tiny
Detail of your Thumb including Dirt . And you
Don't want that Ending Up in your Candy. now it's Time to get Start Molding our Thumb
Grab a small Handful of each color Putty so that the two together Have about the same volume as your Trimmed-Down
Cup if it seems like you have more of One Color Putty than the other Just Add a little bit more until they Seem even
Now, we're Going to mix These two together until, We have one Smooth color We Should Get a, lighter Purple.
Try to Knead The Putty Quickly Because you have a limited Work Time Usually only A couple Minutes
Once You're Finished Mixing you Should have one Smooth Consistent color with no Streaks in it this Stuff Feels kind
of like a stiff Play-doh
Or
Maybe Silly Putty Press a little bit of Silicone Down Into The Bottom of the Cup and Then Begin Wrapping your Thumb in the rest
of the Putty
Press your thumb with the Putty Around it down Into the Cup and Begin Squishing Down all of the Sides all the Way Around you
Want to Press hard Enough to remove Most of the air Bubbles and to be sure that the Putty Is Forming A good seal Around
Your Thumb this ensures that your mold will pick up every Detail of your thumb Down to the fingerprints the Putty Takes two
Or Three Minutes before it Begins to stiffen so try and get your Thumb molded before then
Once it's Begun Hardening it's a little bit Less Flexible and a little bit more Durable it will Take About 15
Minutes for This Silicone to Cure Completely
So just be Patient!
Update on Where
We are now we've Made Two molds one of my thumb in One of Grant's it's Time to start making Candy the basic Recipe for
This Candy is super Simple it's 2 Cups of White sugar 2/3 Cups light Corn Syrup and
3/4 Cups Water Add All Those ingredients to your Saucepan and Set the stove to medium Heat using your heat-Resistant
Spatula Mix all Those ingredients until the sugar is Dissolved
Once The sugar is Dissolved it's actually Time to stop stirring at this Point mixing too much Could actually ruin your Candy and the Bubbling
Action From The sugar will Circulate it Within the pan as your Mixture is Boiling out the Excess Water
The Candy Thermometer will Probably Stay Around 200 degrees Fahrenheit for a while you need to
Be sure that the Head of your Candy Thermometer is Submerged in your Mixture but not Touching the side or Bottom of your pan as
This Could Throw Off The Temperature Measurement While your Candy Mixture is heating Up it's Time to choose what Flavor and color you
Want your Thumbsucker to be?
Since I'm going with the orange Cream Flavor I'm going to try and use the red and Yellow Food coloring to get an Orange Thumbsucker
Now you want a lollipop stick and A Clothespin so that when our Candy is Done Cooking we'll be all ready to Make our Thumb.
Center it's a simple Thing to Position the lollipop stick Where you're going to want it and Hold it in Place With your Clothespin
Keep A close Eye on your Candy Thermometer when it hits 260 degrees Fahrenheit it's Time to add your color
Even After Adding the Food Coloring you
Don't want to stir the mixture Let the Bubbling Action mix the color in for you as the Temperature Keeps rising Watch it very Carefully
You'll Need To remove it from the heat the instant it hits 300 degrees Fahrenheit
Any Longer and the sugar will start To Burn Let the Candy mix cool
Down Just Enough to stop Bubbling and then Add your Flavoring
Be Careful as the Steam From the Rapidly Heating Flavor extract Could Cause, Small Splashes of molten Sugar
Alright Guys our Mixture. Is hot Just off the stove I've Added the flavouring it's Time to pour it Into our mold
Of Course if You want to speed up the cooling Process you can Pop the whole mold Into the Refrigerator for A few Minutes
For Easy Cleanup fill your Pot With hot Water and boil it on the stove the Heat will Help Melt and Dissolve the sugar so
It Comes Off Quickly and Easily if You Have a Certain color you want to achieve you can
Practice With About Two cups of Water in A glass this way you Can Figure out Exactly how
Many Drops of Each Color Food Coloring you need Without Ruining A
Whole Batch of Candy Grant Wanted his Thumb to be Root Beer-Flavored so we're Going for a nice Brown color
Alright Guys Update we've Finished our Candy Poured them Into our Thumb Molds and They've cooled Down to the point where They're Ready to be
Pulled Out if You, were Having a hard Time Pulling your Thumb out when you're
the mold it's possible you're Going to need to cut. The side of the silicone to get the lollipop to come out Smoothly
Well my Cousins might Have
There you have it guys There's A cast of my Thumb in Candy you can see These
Imperfections in The Cast That's From Where I wasn't Careful Enough Wrapping the Silicone Around my thumb so make sure you do A very good?
Thorough Job of getting it to cover all the Details Something Else is Really, Interesting About this silicone Mold Putty is Look
How much Detail it picks up you Can Actually See some of my Thumbprint in the Lollipop I guess There's Really
One Test that Matters the Most and that's how Does it taste I
Used Orange Cream Flavor that's got a great orange Flavor to it it's Nice and Sweet and the
Shape is great it Fits right in your. Mouth it's a little Strange Feeling the Thumbprint on my tongue as well
After Pouring the Thumbs, We still Had a little bit of Leftover Candy Mixture so we tried Pouring some Candy Lego Blocks and Minifigures
okay, so the Candy Stayed Stuck to the Plastic Lego Sheet and Completely Released from the silicone Mold I Didn't see That Coming but I
Hope it means that we've got good Indentations on the back of These pieces
That's Looking decent I don't think this is enough that
We Can pick up quite enough Detail to really get the pieces to Lock together
The Syrup when it Comes right out of the Pot is Still Fairly Thick and it has A hard Time getting Into all the Tiny
Little Nooks and Crannies That you need to Really get A, functional Lego Piece
on solo in Candy IT--
All Right There you have it guys that's how to take Just A few Simple Ingredients and Make your Own Candy and
You've Learned how to mold and Cast your Own Thumb so that you can
Make A customized Thumbsucker Lollipop using These Same techniques you Can mold all sorts of Things you can See our Lego and Jewels that
We made out of Candy Now if You liked this Video you know what to do?
Thanks for Joining Me for This Project I'll be Looking for you the next one Talk to you then
It's weirder if You're Eating someone Else's Mark Tried my thumb isn't that isn't that weird hello, Hello Yellow
These do not Protect from Heat Enough my Hands Hurt A lot in fact that might be the Thumbnail
Hey Guys Just want to Pop in With A quick announcement this Week I'm hitting A Huge Milestone with my wife it is our 10
Year Anniversary
We're Heading out to the Island of Kauai for two Weeks with no Kids
Just Us so the Plan for the Video is Guys I vas innate to step in and Take
Over the next Six Videos for you it's Just gonna be his Lovely face to treat him
Well leave Them a good Comment and I'll be Looking for you when I get back Talk to you then
you